beth and rip i think the reason why
people in my my theory is is that you
know they're not perfect you know and
they they have their struggles they have
their issues and i think you know a lot
of the audience looks at that and they
you know whether they are having those
same issues or not you know probably not
as intense but i think that they're
challenged in so many different ways but
they have each other and what happens is
when they're together they open up so
they get to see you know the armor come
off i think that's why they've fallen
and love is it's just not
that perfect like you know kind of you
know relationship it's it's real rip and
bass get married in true rip and beth
fashion
it was my mother's ring
we didn't have much breath we're poor
but
it's yours
and so am i
i now pronounce you husband and wife
[Music]
what was the significance of that moment
and as an actor who's been with her for
four seasons now and it being a slow
burn for your character's relationship
to to finally tie the knot what was that
like i mean the way it went down it was
pretty wild um you know her storming in
and her gold dress and
her dad and kevin and i looking at her
and going what in the hell is she up to
now and then coming out and that she has
a priest that she's kidnapped i mean it
was just wild and even as an actor
you're sitting there going starting to
put all the things together and connect
all the dots and you're like this is
crazy
and then lloyd comes in i go get him and
there's that moment with us because you
know i've been kicking his ass all year
because he ain't listening but um
you know it all comes together and
there's actually this beautiful moment
there together and i know you've seen it
but yeah i haven't but i did it and i
felt like it was it is crazy and weird
and as a whirlwind kind of
marriage as you could put on a screen i
thought it was pretty uh pretty touching
in the end
and now miss dutton repeat after me i
best done yes i do
um not yet
i love their wedding and it's just so
typical beth that she's just not
interested in how a wedding party or a
wedding dress or any all she cares about
is being
his wife and and and and
because she's she knows that she's just
about to ruin her life you know the next
day so it's like i'm going to go out his
wife there's something i don't know i
kind of find her slightly heroic in a
really messed up way thank you uh
[Music]
thank you for doing this father oh
you're welcome
and uh don't worry
i won't press charges charges sorry
daddy yeah i had to kidnap him
it's hilarious and poetic at the same
time it's just perfect it's the perfect
way when i read that it made me laugh
because i knew
i knew we were going to get married this
season but i didn't know how and then he
set it up that we're going to go find
this beautiful spot to do it in and and
of course that doesn't ever happen she's
right we're doing it now here i loved it
like she's throwing the chairs out of
the way and you know
strutting down the yeah
just this with that with that crazy
outfit from the prison right yeah
perfect way for a perfect couple
[Music]
you